let's begin this hour with a new
approach to a global problem in our
earth 365 series we focus on issues that
affect our world year round today we're
focused on the confusion around
recycling last year the u.s generated
nearly 40 million tons of plastic waste
but only five to six percent of it was
recycled folks that's partly because
many of us struggle with what exactly
can be recycled especially when it comes
to plastic bags and packaging so meg
oliver wrote along with the new jersey
pilot program that's helping residents
get it right meg help us out good
morning good morning vlad an
overwhelming majority of americans want
to recycle we often put items like
plastic bags into bins hoping they'll be
recycled but this so-called wish cycling
can do more harm than good
got that one the first wednesday of
every month
starting at 7 a.m six public utility
workers canvas redbank new jersey in
search of white buckets full of plastic
film
so how many miles do you cover when
you're doing this
well we do the whole time foreman don
andrews says in just a few hours his
team collects enough to fill several
trucks wow that didn't take long for you
to fill that up
hard plastics like bottles and takeout
containers can be recycled in curbside
bins soft plastics like bags wrap and
mailers most often cannot the difference
is often lost on well-intended consumers
i've always been into recycling very
much but i didn't realize the plastic
film was a separate thing
this pilot program gives residents the
convenience of curbside recycling
through a separate plastic film pickup
in the sound of nearly 13 000 people
hundreds are participating did you
realize how much plastic film actually
existed in your house no that's what i'm
saying and i'm an
environmentalist red bank council
president kate trigiano says the program
appealed to the town's environmentally
conscious population it really is
something that's so prevalent in our
lives and it's something that cannot be
taken in the regular recycling stream
we followed the plastic from red bank to
a recovery facility
where recyclables are sorted and bundled
for final processing
there we saw household waste from other
sources with bags mixed in with paper
and cardboard a big problem because
plastic film will jam the machines this
stuff can be very detrimental to the
system it can wrap around
a lot of the shafts a lot of the
bearings operations manager carlos
batista says he needs to shut down the
facility for two hours every day to
remove it it could actually cause either
fire or mechanical damage the plastics
industry keeps telling us oh we can
recycle everything so i've created a
collection
all these things aren't recyclable but
yet they're labeled telling us they're
recyclable jan dell is fighting plastic
pollution through her organization the
last beach cleanup she recently
co-authored a report that claims only
five to six percent of all plastic waste
in the u.s is actually recycled and
particularly post-consumer plastic film
there's no evidence that any of that is
getting recycled
it's just too hard to collect it's all
types of different plastics and they
can't be recycled together
many product labels tell consumers they
can recycle film at store drop-off
locations but dell says the plastic
collected at these sites is often so
contaminated with other garbage it can't
be recovered and worse so by putting all
these these recycle symbol on these
things when they're actually not
recycled and then confusing consumers to
think they can just put them in the bin
is really bad we have inconsistent
guidelines lack of consumer education
and really a confusing process where
most consumers don't know what goes in
the bin
joshua baca is with the american
chemistry council which represents
chemical and plastic manufacturers he
says the industry is working to ensure
more plastic packaging can be remade
into new products billions of dollars
has been invested in advanced recycling
technology that is critical for
recycling more of the film that we use
today and frankly there is a huge demand
for recycled material
but dell says cost is a major hurdle
towards realizing those goals there just
really aren't plastic processing
factories in the us who want to buy
waste plastic and try to turn it into
new plastic
why because new plastic is so cheap this
is probably at best a b grade film weeks
after our visit the plastic film from
red bank was still waiting for a
processor to accept it and use it to
make a new product
it's a critical step on the road from
waste to recycled
our systems have not caught up with our
desire to recycle until they do if you
want to do right by the environment do
not mix plastic film in the bin with
other recyclables unless you've got a
program like red banks it's better to
take it to a store drop off site or just
throw it away we were a little
disappointed we wanted to see this
program go full circle from pickup to
the processor but as you saw it's still
sitting there it will eventually get
picked up recycling is so complicated
you need like a law degree and a ph.d
fix to read the can and then you ever go
to the you cut like a piece of trash and
you show up and then they have three
holes yeah like i don't know where do
you go but i think it's yes people want
to do the right thing i think that's the
message i agree with people want to do
the right thing and they attempt to do
the right thing but it is very confusing
sometimes you look at the bottom who can
remember what the numbers mean
and it's a weekly thing i mean honestly
i've given up on i i try to recycle the
big things but as a solution for our big
problems in this country i've given up
on it the best approach is to try to buy
a glassware that you can reuse right
rather than recycle reuse is something
that i think is more valuable at the
moment
meg oliver we thank you always good to
have you here i should say i covered
this three years ago three years ago
yeah and how much has changed not a lot
not a lot yeah it was a good story
tonight and they're in lies of problems
right